along with a growing number of
infections the corona virus is spreading
fear and discrimination against
asian-americans restaurants and other
businesses in cities from New York to
California have reported big drops in
sales we're also learning about reports
of racist incidents at hotels and
bullying of asian-american students we
shashank visited a struggling Chinese
restaurant in New York City Weiser what
did you learn oh good morning Anthony it
is clear that Asian Americans are facing
discrimination over a disease that does
not discriminate the CDC says Asians are
not more likely to contract or spread
coronavirus than anyone else
politicians are now working to combat
racism but one restaurant owner we spoke
to said the damage is done
how has coronavirus impacted your
business tremendous king lambs family
has owned a popular New York City dim
sum restaurant for more than four
decades he's been through SARS you've
been through swine flu is coronavirus
different when it comes to business yes
and then when you talk about salon swine
flu and h1n1 we didn't feel anything at
all
lamb says he's lost 1.5 million dollars
and business is down around 50% what do
you think the reason is because Chinese
started the the coma virus which is a
scare to get infected by Chinese people
and they think Chinese people had a
Chinese rises yes and it's not just at
restaurants so what was that to do with
us last month the man posted videos on
Facebook that appear to show employees
at two hotels in Indiana turning him
away so no agents there
why is that
because the virus CBS News reached out
to the alleged victim but did not hear
back
Windham hotels and resorts which owns
both hotels said in a statement they are
deeply troubled by these incidents as
they are not reflective of our values or
our expectations of franchisees and
they're treating this matter seriously
the racism has also surfaced in
classrooms in Madison Wisconsin school
officials say there's been comments made
toward Asian students and they're
working to stop those responsible in
really seizing that moment to educate
that student so they you know understand
that their words have meaning and can be
hurtful it's not just in the u.s. Asians
around the world have reported
discrimination linked to coronavirus he
sheltered
I don't want your coronavirus in my
country Jonathan mock is a student from
Singapore studying in London he told the
BBC he was walking down the street last
week when four people attacked him
she's such a serious problem that has
plagued us for a very long time there's
also been apparent attacks in New York
City posted on social media
Peter ku is a councilman in Flushing
Queens a predominantly Asian
neighborhood asian-americans are just
like other Americans we are all
successful to wireless in other major
cities across the country politicians
have tried to combat racism and Miss
information there's been a lot of
xenophobia against folks who are part of
our Asian community showing support at
rallies and by dining in restaurants but
Lam worries the road to recovery is a
long one
it sounds like Corona is crippling
businesses it's booming community it is
do you think the damage is done the
damage is already done
it's already done Liam Toros business
continues to drop every day and he
doesn't think they have seen the worst
of it yet the New York State Assembly
just passed a measure that allows the
governor to direct emergency funds to
small businesses impacted by coronavirus
noise I agree with that signed fight the
virus not the people who have it
that's all right it's very important
that you're doing this story though we
should to let people know that this is
happening and that it really is not ok
well the community feels like you know
they're fighting to diseases exactly the
disease of corona but also bigotry and I
really feel for those young kids
especially our Americans that are being
made to feel like the other yeah we sure
thank you very much thank you